لا سمح الله ، أنا هنا غدًا
إذا كان هناك زلزال
وبعد هذا الزلزال
إذا كانت هناك عواقب لا يمكننا استيعابها
ماذا سنفعل إذن
[موسيقى]
لدي طلب منك.
ضد البناء القبيح
في التحول الحضري ومشاريع التغيير
الرجاء دعم مساعدتنا
يكون
أنا لا أقول هذا دون أن أؤذيك.
دعونا نتكاتف في المباني الحديثة Ordulu
آمل أن نتمكن من مقاعد زملائي المواطنين
[موسيقى]
ومن وزير التعمير و
من عمدة أفيون قره حصار
يفي بوعده ويلغي المشروع
نحن ننتظره أن يأتي إلى مصر
اتركه كما هو
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن الآن في كل فرصة ليلا ونهارا.
الاهتمام يتجه إلى Maraş على Twitter
نكتب هناك نكتب هنا
نحن نقول
[موسيقى]
اريد منك سنة واحدة
بنعمة الله خلال عام
سنقوم ببناء الانشاءات
سنقوم أيضا
[موسيقى]